the traffic and navigation app Waze is
launching a new carpooling service today
across California passengers can request
a ride with someone already driving
along their route it will only cause
them a share of the gas money
other ride-hailing apps like uber and
lyft have already connected millions
with their carpooling options but long
before they came along there was casual
carpool this grassroots commuting option
has sprung up in Washington DC in
Houston - John Blackstone recently
tested the concept where it all started
the San Francisco Bay Area all right I'm
ready for some coffee
it's shortly after 8:00 a.m. on a
typical weekday morning and both Meghan
Christensen and Shoshana Gould are
getting ready for work they live within
blocks of each other in Oakland
California but it never met
hey good morning good morning Darya I'm
gonna let me Johanna yeah I'm join you
for your commute here these both women
work about 10 miles away across the bay
in downtown San Francisco and both face
the same frustrating traffic obstacle
known as the maze three major
interstates all converge at the East End
of the Bay Bridge creating a bottleneck
that often delays drivers by more than
an hour for almost 40 years the solution
for thousands of commuters like
Christiansen and Gould has been
something called casual carpool this is
it somebody just pulls up yeah just get
in the car
hi hi good morning good morning how are
you good how are you at more than 20
locations scattered throughout the East
Bay region people who need a ride into
San Francisco line up each weekday
morning and jump into the next card
pulls up it's like ad-hoc carpooling
yeah yeah typically the rider is
expected to chip in $1 for the toll
here's my dollar by the way oh thank you
you're welcome
but the real draw for solo drivers like
Kristensen adding if these two
passengers gives them access to this
a restricted carpool lane onto the
bridge big traffic jam Wow
so doing this we're saving thirty five
minutes something like that
probably probably about that yeah about
six thousand people are doing this daily
University of California Berkeley
researchers Susan Shaheen is one of the
few social scientists who've studied
this almost 40 year old phenomenon that
was born during a crippling 1979 public
transit strike we found that the median
wait time for a driver was just two
minutes and they were doing this long
before lyft and uber the casual
carpooling gets done without an app and
it just works it's completely organic
here we are in the home of high tech and
and this low tech system is is thriving
and has been for years
you don't need an app to do everything
there are ways to live your life with
other well some casual car pooler's are
attracted to the system's analog appeal
many feel it was the modern sharing
economy that erased fears about getting
into a stranger's car the tech world has
actually made us a little bit more
trusting of people around us because we
hop in the car all the time with uber
drivers and lyft drivers yeah I feel
like if you can rent a room in a
stranger's apartment and sleep there
comfortably then you can get a ride
comfortably with a stranger in this city
okay well thanks for the ride all right
thank you thank you in an age when uber
claims its users have taken more than
600 million uber pool rides and lyft
boasts of 28 million rides on its lift
line feature casual carpool is the
little transit system that predates them
all and shows no signs of slowing down
it's so organized but it's also so
casual exactly passional carpool for CBS
this morning John Blackstone San
Francisco sharing is part of our time
now sharing is caring but not for me
yeah I just think you're too intimate to
me in a car that way you don't want to
just be with a stranger they may meet
someone but what about a mommy I'll keep
working on some other way but an Airbnb
you can go into a room and close the
door Kirby did that to me in an uber we
stopped him the stranger got in I go who
was this person
don't ever do that to me again but I
think it works for Peter was a cheaper
ride yes